hello and happy April the first
otherwise known to some as April Fool's
Day a day in which people play pranks
and jokes on each other in the name of
camaraderie and on this particular April
first I want to show you a glimpse a
glimpse into a mirror universe if you
will and I'm gonna do it but the help of
this the remote control of imagination
with it we can traverse space and time
go forward and backward through time and
peer into other dimensions and realities
and on this particular trip I'm going to
send you to the year 1997 of this mirror
universe to see a review of a film a
film that lives in infamy to us and is
quite beloved by them and as you're on
this trip I ask you to ponder to
yourself
are they the mirror universe or are we
and I send you there on your trip now
[Music]
I'll tell you what 1997 has been pretty
generous to us so far we have the Star
Wars special editions Godzilla kicked
ass and now we have Batman and Robin so
Batman and Robin is not just a new film
by Joel Schumacher it's the newest
Batman film sequel to Batman Forever we
have poison ivy and mr. freeze played by
uma Thurman and Arnold Schwarzenegger
and then we have Batman played by George
Clooney this time Chris O'Donnell once
again is Robin we have Alicia
Silverstone as Batgirl now gonna walk
you through the plot on this one I
really feel like you should watch this
film for yourselves because when I
walked out of this movie I feel like I
saw something special this might be a
game changer for comic book movies and I
really mean that first of all George
Clooney is Bruce Wayne / Batman George
Clooney brings this Adam West quality to
the film but throwing it back to the old
school days of Batman freeze you're mad
it's camp that works for what they're
going for keeping on with the brilliant
superb and perfect casting in this film
Arnold Schwarzenegger as Mr Freeze mr.
free is one of my personal favorites
from Batman the Animated Series played
by Arnold Schwarzenegger mr. freeze is
an emotionless villain a very tragic
story who better to play an emotionless
villain than Arnold Schwarzenegger who
became famous playing a robot rather
Cyberdyne systems model 1-0-1 not a
robot a cyborg who could have been more
perfect to play him nobody the Arnold
puns I mean Arnold Schwarzenegger he's
known for his Arnold puns and he does
have these Arnold puns in this film but
what are puns dad jokes
what are dad jokes bad
these puns are perfect dad jokes perfect
in representing someone who's trying to
emulate humor but is emotionless so he
doesn't quite get it I thought it was
brilliant and some moments of humor in
this film are actually a prelude or a
precursor to a possible crossover chicks
dig the car this is why Superman works
alone I don't know how they're gonna
make that work I mean in the world of
comic book movies movies that is you've
gotta kind of stick in your lane and
keep it in the pocket a Batman Superman
movie don't know if it can work but it
works for the animated series as did the
Superfriends as would The Avengers but
you could never bring those to the big
screen that could never work just a fact
of life but I appreciated the reference
now my thermic plays poison ivy does she
overact in the movie absolutely she's a
bit campy but like I said to bring in
the camp back to it as scene with George
Clooney as Bruce Wayne and Batman
but the contrast between uma thurman's
villain poison ivy and Arnold
Schwarzenegger's mr. freeze a villain
that is passion and Schwarzenegger who
is dispassion I love that dynamic
between the two essentially you have hot
and cold and those aren't the only two
characters in this film that share a
connection now mr. freeze and Batman
share a connection I felt was so
powerful because this entire film is
about family and connection but these
two men are trying to control life and
death and as they're learning in this
film it's impossible to do so but I
can't can I
none of us can if you look back at the
Batman films before this one no villains
share such a connection with Batman as
Mr Freeze does in this film as a knee
Riddler fun to watch two-face we didn't
really get the backstory so they don't
share that connection penguin no
Catwoman romance with Bruce Wayne no
such connection Joker and the original
Joker created Batman Batman created
Joker okay that's the connection but not
since then mr. freeze and Batman they
sure are much closer connection than
either of them really not but by the end
they might learn it though gotta watch
it to find out
that's for at least you Silverstone as
Batgirl they do change the Batgirl
storyline Batgirl is now
Alfred's niece in this film unexpected
absolutely but they bring it closer to
home they add to the family dynamic that
otherwise wouldn't have been there and I
will say Alfred in this film has much
more to do he's much more important in
this story than he's ever been in a
Batman film before if there's one thing
we know about Alfred is he will go
against Bruce Wayne's wishes if it's the
thing for the city because alfred loves
this city in fact like bruce wayne tells
him in this film not all heroes wear
masks alfred is a part of the team he is
a hero among this story the bat suits
themselves once again we saw this in
Batman Forever and we see it once again
in Batman and Robin the bat suits once
again are a celebration of the human
form you see Joel Schumacher is taking
it back
not just with some of the camp going
back to the Adam West Batman but he's
going back to win DC heroes were they
were extraordinary otherworldly they
were gods the Statue of David come to
life right before your eyes or the Greek
statues of old you really get that
feeling that these suits are
representing gods among men complete
with nipples and look at these glutes
I'd be remiss if I once again didn't
touch on the contrast between hero and
villain the bad suits representing the
human physical body a mr. Freeze's suit
representing a mechanical body a
mechanical prison for the body as it
were Baines is actually in this film too
I mean he is different than how he's
been represented before but it's been
around for about five years not exactly
like he's a classic but Bane does add to
what Joel Schumacher is representing in
this film which is humanity in this film
it said Bane is operating on his impulse
his limbic system who's teamed up with
poison ivy who was basically passion
incarnate so in this film you have the
it'd ito and super-ego I don't mind
saying I think Freud would be very proud
of Batman and Robin that's one of the
many reasons I'm saying this is a leap
forward for comic book film so no matter
how you're looking at the connection
between the characters whether it be the
villains the heroes the villains and the
heroes one thing you know is that you
are looking through a microscope to the
core of humanity and I know that for a
fact and we'll take it one step further
in addressing that IV who is all passion
and Victor fries who is seemingly devoid
of it if you look deeper at mr. Freeze's
motivation he's not devoid of it at all
his motivation in this film again don't
want to spoil it for you but his
motivation is he's looking for these big
diamonds to complete a freeze gun in
which he's going to freeze Gotham and
hold it for ransom for money after I
walked out of it I was like why would he
not just sell the
diamonds for the money whereas I was
almost quick to write that off as a
writing loophole or sloppy writing at
best you take a moment to think about it
it's not that in fact it's much deeper
than I was prepared to process freezes
real motivation is he wants to lash out
at Gotham he wants to hurt the city that
hurt him which is not dispassion and
that's what Batman and Robin is teaching
us is that no matter what happens we are
not free of the shackles of desire we
are not devoid of being human and in
touching so deeply and so thoroughly to
the core of humanity sprinkled
throughout this film is the lesson of
hubris it's everywhere in here not just
Robin who on quite a few occasions in
this film represents it very thoroughly
but at a surface level he's cocky he's
arrogant Bruce Wayne shut him down right
there that conflict is he's cocky Bruce
Wayne's cocky their ideologies are
clashing like any roommate situation
they're clashing at this point getting
ugly in the cage but there's one scene
in here and I'm just there's a scene
where they're at an auction everyone's
bidding on poison ivy because you know
she's desire incarnate in Batman and
Robin start going at it and they just
start throwing these bids 1 million two
million Batman with zero air of caution
whatsoever is simply just throwing out
numbers that lets everyone in the room
know that he is in fact rich this is
monumental for the Batman films we've
never seen this this were a lesser film
I would say it's plagued with bad
writing but this being Batman and Robin
I can assure you I can tell you this is
a fascinating display of psychology in
the films before this he never would
have done that he would have made sure
he'd never give any clues as to his
identity but here in Batman and Robin
he's been Batman for so long he is
literally losing himself in the role the
lines between Bruce Wayne and Batman
they're becoming fuzzy they're blurring
in essence he's going and say this like
something out of a graphic novel
actually read very recently called
Watchmen it's written by an author named
Alan Moore if you haven't read Watchmen
go to your local Barnes & Noble or
borders books and they should have it
it's like a lesson that would be touched
on and there I just I wasn't used to a
comic book movie getting so deep
my ears were plugged again cuz it got
that deep in the end I hope audiences
are ready for Batman and Robin it's a
bit unconventional the contrast between
the camp it brings to the comic book
element but the depth in which it dives
into humanity connections life and death
I hope people are ready for that
I mean cherry on top not to spoil it for
you but I'm used to my comic book movies
having at least one of the villains die
but they both live in here Mr Freeze and
poison ivy both live but Batman in
saving mr. freeze allows mr. freeze to
save Victor freeze will you help me just
say I hope you're ready I think it's
safe to say the future of Batman is
looking very bright after this this is
one small step for film but one giant
leap for comic book movies and they're
already talking to Madonna for the role
of Harlequin it almost feels like they
might be running out of villains but
they still have calendar man
eggheads the limit all I know is there
are some villains that should never be
redone because no one's ever going to
top Jack Nicholson's Joker ever just
leave that alone
those two thinks I know for sure Batman
and Robin is a masterpiece of comic book
film and they should leave Jack
Nicholson's Joker hello alright so
Batman and Robin have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
think please let me know in the comments
and now as before if you want to see
more and you like what you've seen click
right here to see more and there we are
a universe like our own except for one
very important detail they like a movie
we consider infamous and they probably
consider infamous that which we love
are they the reflection of us or are we
simply the reflection of them until we
know none of us can sleep safely in our
beds or chills
[Music]